I am a Rasmus Paludan,
leader of the Stram Kurs party in
Denmark and also journalist and editor
of Frihedens Stemme or in English the
Voice of Freedom. And what we're going
to do here is not really just an
interview with Raymond Ibrahim, the
famous scholar of Islamic history and
the treatment of non-Muslims by Muslims
in the world, but also kind of an
conversation. So, we're also going to
talk to you. You're actually also going
to ask me questions.
>> Yeah, excellent. Let's start by you
telling us how you became notorious.
Well, you know,
in Denmark, we had until 2017 a
blasphemy law.
So, you weren't allowed to do anything
that offended a religion. It hadn't
really been used for like 70 years.
People had done stuff with with Jesus
Christ that to some people would be very
offending, but nothing had really
happened. So, in reality,
it had lost all importance except
possibly that you couldn't burn the
Quran or the Bible, possibly. And of
course, I thought it just that. He
burned the the Quran in his own garden
and and put it on video and said it it
smells really bad. And then then the
prosecution, they they started a case
against him. They indicted him for
blasphemy, and I was actually his
defense attorney.
And
because already then I was starting to
see that Islam in Denmark is a very bad
combination. That was There were many
reasons for this, but you know, safe to
say,
growing up, there was one Denmark and
then I
found out there was another Denmark and
I didn't like it at all. He was indicted
and before he was actually brought to
trial,
the majority of parliament decided to
repeal the provision.
So, they repealed the blasphemy law in
2017 because of that case. And and and
then he the the case was dropped by the
prosecution because it's no longer
illegal.
Then what happened was I started my
party in 2017 and
half a year before that I started the
the online newspaper the Voice of
Freedom and
we started just doing stuff that we had
to understand this was unheard of. That
was outrageous to do something in public
like this in Denmark. Nobody had done
it.
Um so I was
having more of a contact with the
security police and they told me if you
hand out folders with a picture of
Muhammad they will kill you possibly and
we can't protect you because we don't we
don't see the threat in time you'll be
killed is our thought. So he was like
listen to this like everybody can do it.
It wasn't serious stuff.
But we kind of did that anyway more or
less and we visited the areas with a lot
of
of Muslim inhabitants and we didn't
bring Qurans but we said stuff like
criminals
losers are very bad. And
you know if somebody said that in my
neighborhood I wouldn't really care but
apparently all of them that live there
thought that I meant them and they were
very offended so
and so apparently it's like who's a
loser? Uh
How dare you offend me? So and then in
the beginning of 2019 I was just like
maybe we should do something more. So I
said now we'll start doing something
with the Quran like burning it or
putting bacon under it or whatever to
show our disgust for this message.
Um
then the security police went nuts
and said you know
you'll probably killed. It's very
dangerous. We can't say that you can't
do it because it's legal but you know
it's very dangerous.
And I was like
okay that's not good and they met with
me like three times a week to
underline this.
But eventually we we did it and and I
didn't actually to be fair
other people did it in the processes I
was leading. I didn't personally do it
until
one and a half year later but other
people did and I was completely
supportive of that.
And that led to um
more and more violence against me and
and actual violence Oh, no, actual
violence. You were attacked or people
wanted to I'm sure they wanted to. Oh,
absolutely they wanted to, but I was
attacked.
I wasn't like beaten up bloody, but but
that was because I was prudent and had
police often. Which also annoyed the
violent fellows, I think, but eventually
it all it all um
the Sunday before Easter Sunday in 2019,
I went to a very Muslim area in
Copenhagen. Mhm. And and they um
they just went nuts
and burned everything down and attacked
the police and and the newspapers and
the television had to focus only on that
because half of Copenhagen was like in
fire. Uh
so, and that's where I went from being a
YouTube phenomena for young people,
particularly young males, because you
know, if you experience some of the
problems I highlighted and you will if
you're a young Danish guy, then you're
more supportive of my views. That's
makes sense. Uh but but on that date I
went from a YouTube very famous person
among people from ages 12 to 25 until
everybody. Mhm. Um so, that was like the
first big thing um and we missed
parliament by points
uh 0.02%.
So, that was a shame. Mhm. Yes.
Um so, we had that 2% and we had 1.8%,
so
um So, okay. Um and ultimately I assume
you what you and others are trying to do
is make a point which is that um you
know, freedom of expression is the most
important thing. And these people can't
tolerate it. And in other words, I
always think of course and I'm sure
people have made this analogy, which is
what would happen how would the
authorities respond if someone burned
the Bible? Right? And I think we can all
say they would do nothing. Okay, but
they had one one guy did that. He burned
the Bible and the Torah in in the summer
of 2022 here. And nobody did anything.
Okay. So, nobody cares. Okay, so then so
what we're being told now is that um
laws are dictated on how much any
particular people respond with violence,
right? Yeah. That's what it is. So, if
if if you don't like what I'm going to
say and you burn down a house, then
we're going to shut down what I say.
It's like Isn't that that's just a
deterrent?
I asked this question to to um
as you know, I'm also a lawyer. So, I
was at a meeting of lawyers in 2022,
which was all the Nordic lawyers met to
discuss law.
>> Mhm. And there was a panel about this
Quran burning ban. And I said, like, why
is it so offensive to burn the Quran,
but not offensive to believe that you
should cut the throat of the infidel? Uh
I mean, isn't that more offensive? Good
question.
And and as scholar from Norway had the
guts to answer, well, I can explain this
to you. They they think it's more
offensive because the reaction is much
more violent. That's why. So, they
admitted it. Yeah. I mean, she agreed
that it makes no logical sense. It's
just because the reaction is so much
more violent, you assume that is worse
or more offensive, but of course it's
not because writing that you can cut
someone's throat is more offensive.
Right. Right. Um so, it makes no sense.
So, it but it's a really a a terrible
and dangerous precedent because what
you're saying is um our free speech is
ultimately based on how any any
demographic reacts. And if you get
angry, then I have to shut up. Yeah. And
that only of course emboldens
That does look like absolutely That's
going to give them more reason to burn
and kill. And you know, it's it's it's
it's it's it's more or less the same
that if you walk in the street and you
see five angry young men and they shout
at you, "What are you looking at?" Then,
you know, you're intimidated. Right. And
you're going to shut up even as they do
bad stuff. So it's really the same thing
just on a macro scale.
>> a thug culture in more
This is really what happens when you put
two groups of people, one with, you
know, high trust, high respect society,
and another one that's thug-a-reet, and
then one just starts giving in because
they're being polite and think it's the
right thing to do. There is no chance
at all of those two cultures being
homogeneous together. Of course not.
They're completely opposite on so many
core issues. Exactly. It's never going
to happen,
and it never has happened.
So, yeah, we're not really so much into
the questions here. It's more like we're
stating the obvious here.
So what What do Okay, what you just said
right there about, you know, Islam and
let's say Western culture being like
water and oil. I said that before.
Um
would the powers that be, the Danish
politicians, you know, leftists,
rightists, whatever, do they get that?
Even I know they'll never say that, but
do you think they get it?
I think
absolutely they don't. They don't get
it.
>> No, no, no.
And and
the reason as I'm
There could be several reasons why they
don't get it. I think, to be fair, most
of them are not very smart because to be
a politician, you don't have to be
clever. You have to have other um
qualities. And they have other
qualities, like saying stuff that makes
them get votes, stuff like that. So
they're not too bright.
Um but also, if you accept that this is
the truth, which some of us do because
we
know stuff.
Then that's That could be to many people
been quite terrifying. You know, that's
That's a terrifying prospect. But then
you kind of some people would morally
feel obligated to actually do something
and heavens, nobody wants to do
anything. Particularly things that
involve, you know, somebody will get
angry and sad. But the angry is a
problem. Sad is not too much problem.
Angry is a problem. And But it's okay
when Muslims get angry.
And what is this like Well, then you
have to cater. The problem is that that
those are the people who would
ultimately get angry. If we said all
Muslims in Denmark have to leave before
noon tomorrow, you know,
many of them would be very angry. And
and you know, they wouldn't say, "We are
very angry and now we're leaving."
That's not the way it works. So, you had
to use violence. I mean, you had to use
legal violence, but you would have to
have you would have to have police
officers or soldiers or whatever who
were capable of using extreme extreme
force.
>> Aren't they? No.
Obviously not.
>> So, even if the government were to
decree Muslims have to leave, the actual
armed forces would not have the
fortitude to do it.
It would have to be a complete
psychological reprogramming. And That's
I agree with that. I I guess I guess,
you know, anything's possible if you
really really, you know, if you know
that your whole family's going to get
murdered, possibly yes. But, you know,
and it's even worse in Sweden. I mean,
there is really they've completely lost.
They don't know that they're living in a
lost country.
>> Now, you're you're half Swedish, half
Danish. Yeah, but to be fair, my father
is from Scania, which was part of
Denmark for most of the history. Okay,
that's Copenhagen was in the middle of
our country.
>> Okay. So, but yeah. You have dual
citizenship. Yes, but I only found that
out before they banned me from Sweden
for being a menace to society. And then
they found out that they'd actually
violated the old constitution by banning
a citizen.
And thanking them for that, I ran for
the parliamentary elections in Sweden in
'22, and the exact same thing happened
only with an attitude of like 10 times.
So, on the Sunday before Easter, three
years later, on the date,
I I did something in Sweden like a
protest, and they all went completely
crazy. But, they injured 500 police
officers in a matter of three, four
days.
So, it was a lot more violent and
dangerous in in in Sweden than it was in
Denmark. Um they the police had to fire
shots, and actually hit someone with
with bullets,
which is very unusual for Sweden
because, you know, they're more like
what we call coffee and cake kind of
policing where you have to be nice and
we'll give you cake.
Um so, it was You know, and the reaction
was not so much these people are Muslims
and they're reacting as their religion
tells them to. The reaction was that
right-wing extremist from Denmark should
just get the hell out of our country. It
was like, "Okay, well, my genes go back
to your country for generations and the
people you're protecting have been here
for like 5 minutes." Uh
so, I can kind of You know, I understand
this is kind of a very strange society.
>> Right.
So, um here's the last one. Uh you know,
since I've been here in Copenhagen and
I've been speaking to obviously the
people I who invite me and I talk with
are mostly right-wing, so you have to
take that into consideration, but a lot
of them are telling me kind of the
things I never expected to hear, which
is like, for example, there's a a strong
mood amongst the Danes where they really
want Islam out. And by that, I thought
they meant, you know, no more migration,
but they were telling me, "No, like
actual re-migration." Kind of like what
Robert Spencer's saying. Um which I find
that, you know, that I
Again, it goes back to the question of
do they have a fortitude? Yeah, I know
they may want it, but do they actually
have what it takes to do something like
that? So, for my first question is, is
that true? Is that a growing mood, let's
say, in Denmark? And even if it is, do
you think that could ever come to
fruition in any fashion?
Certainly true that
more people agree with the basics of
what I said in 2019 than what they did
then. That's true. Right. So, actually
say that that a very large percentage
want them out, I understand that
that's what the polls show, but they're
not voting after that. They're not
voting in accordance with that position.
And And what has happened is that a lot
of the parties, I mean, I was called
sometimes still called at least in
Sweden extremist but I was called an
extremist in 2018 and 19. A lot of what
I said had been adopted by established
parties, even big parties.
But the problem is they're not doing it.
They're saying it but it was just
rhetoric. Yeah. And so maybe it's
rhetoric because that's what the people
want which I still think it itself is a
supposed positive sign but then when
they get into power then they're not
going to go there obviously. So far they
haven't. Certainly I would I mean it's
it's it's been like eight years of talk
and they haven't done it and you know
um
Sure a problem could be the European
Convention on Human Rights Article 8
which like if you've been here and
you're a mass murderer it's okay if your
family is you can stay forever even
though you're not a Danish citizen.
That's certainly that's a problem but
you know if there was political power
you know
you know they really wanted to do
something they could they could just say
you know if you're not a citizen and
you're from a Muslim country you're no
longer welcome here. You'd have to leave
tomorrow. I mean you you can make that
law and then if if the Court in
Strasbourg says that you you you you
can't that was a violation you can say
well we're no longer members. We we we
quit you know. You can do that if you
want to.
There's no um
Those people are from Somalia and
Pakistan and and
Afghanistan. I'm not mentioning the
really bad countries though to be fair
there are a lot of them.
And the Syria and Iraq are not big hits
either.
Um
Just say Muslim world.
They're not part of the European Union.
So there is no European Union protection
as such and
sure some of them could do the Swedish
trick. They could go to Sweden and get
kind of a permit to stay there and then
use their their rights there to go here
and and a lot of them are aware of what
the future might bring because they've
already
gotten Swedish citizenship. So a lot of
them know that the future will bring
stuff so they're trying to hedge their
bets really.
They're much smarter than these, you
know, completely mindless Danes. And
to be fair, the Swedes are worse, but
still.
And the Germans and French or English
are not doing well either.
Most of Western Europe really, as you
know.
So So what do you call this malady? How
do you interpret it? How do you
understand it? Let me just kind of
unpack it what I'm talking about.
One thing I've always noticed and I've
been trying to get to the bottom of is
if I look, okay, you know, Africans,
Arabs, Muslims, Chinese,
Hindus, all these civilizations, they
venerate their past, okay? Whether it
was good or bad and they whitewash it.
It's only whites and Europeans who do
the exact opposite, okay? And I'm saying
this cuz I come from a historical
approach. And so where even where whites
did good things, they're still the bad
guys. So the people who abolish slavery
around the world were Europeans,
Christian Europeans. And for some reason
when you talk about slavery, it's all of
a sudden European Christians are the bad
guys again. All right. In this In this
sort of stuff country.
>> fair, we
The white Europeans didn't usually
castrate the male slaves.
The Muslims did that a lot. That's why
we have no descendants of white slaves
in the Muslim world. Because they were
all castrated. Black slaves, right?
Exactly. So so um So why then the
question becomes why is it that
Where does this come from, this sort of
like self-hate? Even though let's say
all cultures are equal, they should all
They all venerate, okay, but you can
argue European Western civilizations
history has a lot of good stuff, which
is why most of the world wants to go to
live in the West. And why do they How
did this come about? What's the origin
of this self-hatred? Is it Obviously
it's taught. It's not organic. It's not
like people are born this way. It's not
in a gene. So I mean I think a lot of it
goes back to the way history is taught.
For example, the way the way the whole
media set up and the way, you know,
things come up, but let's hear your I
want to hear your European thought. I
This was actually the the main subject
of the interview I did in Washington,
D.C. in 2018, no, 19 with um
Steve Coughlin, who was a former major
in the Joint Chiefs of Staff and did a
analysis of the Muslim Brotherhood.
>> Yeah, I know you know, he was sacked.
So,
um but
I'm not saying that I'm completely
buying his his his version, but I'm
Certainly I think it's difficult if
you're taught that that every value is
equally good because how's how
relativism and that's cultural Marxism
and postmodernism all very, very strong
in Western Europe, not so much anywhere
else.
>> Right. And America also some places.
Right. But I think there are vast areas
of America where it's not so much.
>> Right. And
and how how will you how will you be
proud of your own heritage and your own
mm
way of looking at the world, your own um
culture if you're told that any culture
is equally good? And and you know, so
it's really Sure, there's an
indoctrination by um media and by
teaching in school. There are They they
the teachers in general in Denmark, and
I think that's true many places, are
extremely left-wing and extremely um um
um they shouldn't be teaching. No, no,
they're
but but but they're very
>> They're they're the ones who are most
indoctrinated in, you know, under
progressive postmodernist culturally
Marxist views and and to sum that up is
that everything is equally good and that
the individual is nothing because the
collective is everything. And and um
if if it's difficult to be proud of
anything if you're told that what
whatever you come from is is just
doesn't matter because everything is the
same. And and Well, I agree with you
about the relativism thing, but I I it's
deeper than that because what the way
you're describing it, which is
definitely is definitely a big factor of
it, you would think your culture is no
no better, but not necessarily worse
than the others. But the way I see it,
it's Western people are taught that
their culture is worse. Okay? You should
venerate the American Indian. You should
look up to the noble Muslim, you know,
the noble savage myth. Whereas your
culture brings nothing but genocide and
evil.
>> That's That's true. I think I think
that's absolutely true. And and
um I think the most extreme example of
that is what is happening or has
happened the past 60 70 years in Germany
because of their guilt the collective
guilt over the the Holocaust.
They they you know, they they're not
proud of being German. And it's not like
German being German was not only Adolf
Hitler. There were other things as well,
you know.
But both things. So So if I was German,
I wouldn't go around saying I'm proud of
being German only because of Adolf
Hitler. I would probably
say in Spider-Man movie I'm proud to be
German. There's some other things
Germans did, right? I could yeah I mean
you know, there are people there.
And and
I think you know, you you can always
find the bad stuff that people have done
in the past. And and I'm looking at it
differently. I don't know this doesn't
really answer your question, but I think
we just have to reiterate that
I'm not I can't take credit for the fact
that white people in Europe created most
of the modern civilization. I can't take
credit for that just because I'm white.
But I shouldn't go around on the other
hand feeling ashamed of a white person
having black slaves 200 years ago
because that wasn't my
thing either. Not to mention everyone
had slaves. Blacks had slaves. Blacks
enslaved whites and Caucasians. I mean
So so so um you know, we we we have a
culture where we reflect a lot more and
where everybody can say anything more or
less except if you criticize Muslims, of
course.
Well, which itself is very italic. Yes.
And and you know, if you are very
critical I mean I think it's fine being
critical yourself historically so that
you don't repeat history.
You shouldn't you shouldn't focus only
on yourself. You should actually focus
on other people as well. And I think in
Denmark at least there's a lot of focus
on what what what have white men done
badly in history and are doing badly
now. And that's that's a problem because
to be fair and this is more or less what
Jordan Peterson says but he didn't
invent this position because everybody
knows this.
It was very difficult being a man
earlier and a woman. It was difficult at
being a child as well. Everybody.
And so to say that just white men were
evil bad people and everybody else were
like saints is like
a turd because it was difficult then and
it's difficult now. Not just as
difficult probably but still difficult.
So nobody's saying life is easy but to
say that because you're a white
heterosexual male then you're very evil
and it's just like you know, well,
excuse me.
Other people did bad stuff as well
and and you know, so
the thing is in our culture you're more
you're more accepting of this and for
some reason and to a large part I think
this is a
a thing between the sexes because
you know, in a Muslim culture if the
woman said
you men have treated us very badly. You
should be ashamed and apologize.
I don't think that would happen. I don't
think first of all they wouldn't say
that but the reaction wouldn't be oh,
we're very sorry.
So
the problem is
you know, I'm all for equality of
opportunity. I'm
really not for result but equality of
opportunity absolutely. But you
shouldn't you shouldn't equality not
equity. Yeah, exactly and and you know,
it's you shouldn't as a man in Denmark
or anywhere
feel, you know, that you have to humble
yourself and apologize for being for
being male for for some females feeling
badly treated because
do do some men treat women badly? Yes.
Do some women treat men badly? Also,
yes. And and this is
this is kind of making mechanics in the
society where you you get used to having
to apologize for not what you have done
but for what you are. And you shouldn't
really apologize for what you are. You
should apologize possibly if you've done
bad deeds. But not for being you. I
mean, you should especially like from a
historical point of view, like you said,
it's even even if like the whites were
the most horrible people, but that's not
you. No, it was
>> What you do was generations ago. So,
what? We believe in punishing, you know,
this the
you know, father's sins.
>> So, all Muslims must be punished and put
to prison because they had castrated
white slaves 30 years ago. That's also a
position, you know? And I think many
African-Americans, they have forefathers
who had slaves in Africa. That's very
bad. What was blacks who enslaved blacks
and sold them to the whites? I don't We
we know this, but most people don't. And
and you know, so it's it's it's
outrageous and I think we should just
take pill and do like the rest of the
world do. Just say, you know, we can
responsible for our own actions but not
for what our forefathers did and not for
being male. I mean, I should not have
blue eyes. I shouldn't I shouldn't
apologize for that.
Bad. Yeah. So, so this and and the
opposite is what is happening that that
you're treated if you're if you're um
if you're a white man or if you're
conservative or if you're just a man,
you're treated badly. And now, because
of that, you're you're you've learned
that it's okay to be treated badly for
those reasons and and of course there is
a backlash because not all men accept
this but but
then you're also buying the idea that
because you're an inhabitant of Denmark
or Sweden
then you're really a bad colonial guy.
So if you see a Muslim on the street per
definition he is the victim. You owe
him. You owe him. So if he raped your
sister, okay, that's wrong.
>> You had it coming. You Yeah, exactly.
Bye-bye. You know, she you know, she
should have been more careful.
>> around comes around.
And
and you know, we can make fun of this.
No, no, I know, but I mean This sounds
ridiculous, but I think That is a
subconscious love. That's a subconscious
reasoning. And and how do you fix this?
Well, I mean, I tried fixing this by
saying, well, I mean, try being proud of
being Christian.
Try trying actually understanding that
for for all its lacking, it's it's
to my opinion you know, less
you know, not so
hard stance against aggressors.
Christianity has actually made some
pretty good countries. Some some of the
best countries in the world.
>> Well, for some reason the whole world
wants to move there. Yeah. So it's not
like Christianity is so bad. It's
actually probably the best compared to
all the rest.
And like democracy is is not all good,
but it's better than a lot of the other
stuff. And and you should try and and
and embrace that and and not apologize
for being Christian or being male and
and and you know, that's that's a
difficult thing because they're taught
the opposite in school. Yeah. Um so
And which is ultimately what I was
trying to get at, which is why are they
told? And I mean, you you mentioned the
Marxist thing. I think it's I while I
agree, I just think it's deeper and
darker than that even. It's um
But anyway, let's
I I you might have had some questions
for me. Absolutely. And and uh you know,
we can still I have a lot of stuff to to
talk about in Norse, but I'm here all
the time and you're only here now, so I
think I should get some in first.
>> Okay. Um
you're an expert in the history of how
Muslims treated the rest of the world
badly. That's would be fair to say.
That's your your your field.
My interest is we've spoken about this
how how you know, they took white slaves
in the millions and castrated them and
and you know, used the women and so
forth. I think that's actually one of
the reasons like the descendants of the
Ottoman
Empire so white, extremely white and
Spanish.
>> Yeah, they're extremely white. It's like
you can't see that they're Turks.
They're not really Turks. Because what
happens is you know, one pure Turk,
let's say, would marry a not marry,
copulate and have a child with a
European.
>> Yeah. That son would be half. He would
marry a slave. That son would be a
quarter. And it would go on. They
actually did a study in in cuz it was
the same thing in Spain where you know,
the the Umayyads would marry the
enslaved Europeans. And the the last one
of their last caliphs, apparently did
some DNA test and he was like 0.05%
Arab. Yeah. And the rest European. Yeah,
absolutely. So so so we know this
happened, but many people are like well,
Christians did bad stuff as well with
the conquistadors. So everybody did bad
stuff in the past. That's all in the
past. Now we're modern. And then I'm
saying, "Hmm, I'm not sure that's so
true." So
in the areas where Muslims actually have
the power,
is it true that they're treating
Christians very civilly and you know,
>> No, not at all. Historically, you know,
you hear about the three choices, right?
Which is uh you know,
which is given to Christians and Jews
per Quran 9:29, which is by the people
of the book
until they either convert or they pay
jizya tribute and feel themselves
subdued, meaning they become dhimmis.
Now that's the official story and um
sometimes it what Muslims did
historically because of course
historically what people do does not
always accord with the teachings of the
religion. But sometimes it was worse
than that. So they would attack, kill,
fight, enslave, okay, slaughter. And
then sometimes of course when it finally
settles down, they would of course by
all means enforce the Dhimmi status.
And that people think, you know, it's
being there's a lot of apologetics about
it now, especially in America. I know
professors. The line now is that the
jizya was actually just a tax that
Christians and Jews had to pay in order
to be exempt from serving in the
military. Okay, which is That's not the
point of the jizya. Yeah, no, no, not at
all. And not the jizya
>> a humiliation tax. Exactly. And it says
it in the Quran. It says they have to
feel themselves humbled. And um, but
it's just ridiculous because no Muslim
army would have ever wanted a Christian
fighting alongside of it in those days.
So then they were exempt because they
were infidels who needed to be
subjugated. And I'm just showing you how
how they they try to whitewash it all
the time, no matter how bad they
>> this was in the past. I'm asking like
what I want to I can tell you what I
want to know really is if this continues
in Europe, so the Muslims in Denmark get
more and more power and eventually they
get the majority, will they still treat
us civilly and and equal rights or what
will happen?
No, they won't.
Um, actually I did a study a while back
where it shows the percentages of
Muslims around non-Muslims and this and
the behavior is always unwavering.
So when they're a tiny minority, 1 2 3%,
that's when screams of Islamophobia
exist, okay, which is a form of control
of speech. When they start growing, 10%
or even a little less, I know a lot of
European capitals have way more than 10%
even though the nations have they say
10% but then you see the criminality,
the thuggery, the sort of uh, you know,
what you have in the UK and in France
and in Sweden. Um, when they when that
number keeps growing out, like let's go
go to Nigeria. That's half Muslim, half
Christian. Full-blown genocide of
Christians because now they're strong
enough to just completely drop the mask
and it's not based on just criminality
and well, you know, trying to get
exploit
it. Let's just kill. And then when you
finally go to like in the Islamic in the
Arab world where Christians are 10%, 5%,
2%, then you have the historic dhimmi
system. And of course, it's not in the
law every unless it's another unless
it's the in Afghanistan. But let's say
Egypt, you know,
in the constitution Christians and
Muslims are equal. But it's become part
of the culture. So, you know,
I have a Christian does something
he's you know, he's trying to build a
church, he's trying to
enlarge his church or something, then
there's a mob attack and the police
stand by for 3-4 hours until
everything's been devastated and no one
gets in trouble, no one's arrested. So,
that's what I mean. It's like it's still
there, it's part of the society, but
it's not on the law, but we all
understand it, wink wink, kind of thing.
Okay, so yeah, that's that's how it is.
But Islam in
Islam never comes just to be, you know,
to to live side by side in harmony. And
there's actual Muhammad says in the
canonical Hadith, Islam Islam brings you
up and nothing brings you up higher.
It's a very like worldly thing. That's
what made it appealing in the first
place. It wasn't some spiritual thing
about salvation. It was about winning
and gaining booty and plunder. Okay, and
so that's the mentality.
Very tribal. Very tribal. I mean, that's
how I always explain it. I say Islam is
just the tribals and deified.
>> And also animalistic really because it
it it it it it extols carnality to no
end. It it it it's the most
basic primal human behavior that
Islam is appealing to. That's that's
what um the earliest Christians and I I
probably young Christian too, but the
earliest Christians
when they studied the Quran and so
forth, I'm talking in the 8th century,
Uh before that, 9th, 10th, people like
um Aquinas,
uh they all said the same thing, which
is like, "What kind of a religion is
this that's obsessed obsessed with sex?
Talking about how you're going to have
supernatural women in heaven with these,
you know, big-bosomed and their eyes are
a certain way and and you get to
devirginize them constantly because
their hymen keeps growing back." I mean,
this is absurd, obviously. This is
heaven's a brothel.
>> It to be fair, you could make the
argument that that Muhammad had the
insight of Freud just a lot earlier. Me
me you know No, but I mean Freud said
everything is about sex more or less as
as comes to human behavior
on the subconscious level and these
course I mean, you can you can factor
that because I think food also is
important, but you know, shelter, but
still
Freud had a point because it was a lot
in that was true.
Um I think
it would be fair to say that in a
society that's very tribal and very
bedouin, those needs are more explicit,
so it makes it easier for Muhammad to
see them because I'm just trying to
understand why Yeah, yeah, well, tribals
you know, nomadic peoples, which is why
it's interesting. If you look
historically, the people who Islam
resonated with and who converted to
Islam were always nomadic peoples. So,
the Arabs, the Berbers, uh the Turks,
the Tatars, all of these you know,
massive peoples became Muslim and
and sub-Saharan Africa, tribal people.
And it is because Islam doesn't really
resonate with sedentary civilized
people, okay? It's based on tribal
mores, which is us versus them, you
know, us and them is everyone outside of
us and they exist to be plundered,
killed, enslaved, raped, whatever, you
know, so Um I've heard a lot with with
the Muslim You have to understand, I've
spoken with a lot of Muslims in Denmark
over the years because they came to my
protests and some of them wanted to buy
a law to convince me of the wonders of
Islam more or less or to understand my
position better.
And some came to to kill me. One
actually had a bigger knife, but he was
shot by the police. He got shot? Yes.
And then he was allowed to stay because
he was mentally ill apparently. Well,
they always are. Yes.
>> That's always the That's the only reason
they could ever do something like that.
Exactly. But um
they say, "What about all the good
Muslims?" And I'm just like, "Well, you
have to define this for me." And I spoke
with a guy yesterday who's a young Turk.
He didn't call himself Turk. He asked He
asked me, "Is Is your position that I'm
a Dane if I have a Dane's passport?" And
I said, "No, it's not. It's not my
position." He He He understood that that
since he's not a Dane in my opinion,
he's you know, it doesn't matter if he
has a passport. But he said,
"Well,
you know, yes, I'm a Muslim, but I don't
really like what you're saying. It says
in the Quran that you should cut throat
of the infidels and I'm not really that
that much into that. I just like the way
we live here in Denmark."
And I'm like, "Okay, well, if that's so
important for you, the way we live here
in Denmark, you should just apostate.
You can just say, 'I don't want to be
Muslim any longer.' Or you can convert
to Christianity or Buddhism or
whatever."
And I'm like, those people they they I
can understand why they want to do that
because the consequences could be
severe. I mean, not maybe not death
here, but certainly they would be
ostracized by their family probably, but
those kind of people
when they're part of the majority, are
they going to change? So, then they will
also I mean, I'm just trying to
understand it. Yeah, well, that's a good
question because
I'm reminded for example in Syria and in
Iraq back when ISIS and the radical
jihadists were taking over in the in
their heyday basically, you know, from
like 2013 to 15, 16,
a lot of later on there were a lot of
interviews with Christians,
Yazidis, and know, you know, Druze, all
these people, but I distinctly remember
reading a long article, I still have
access to it, of Christians who
basically said, you know, we lived we
were shocked because we lived side by
side with our Muslim neighbors
who, you know, for all intents and
purposes are the same people, same
culture, dialect, you know.
And the only difference is religion. And
and they said we we live we were like
family to them, we took it and the
Christians would often help the Muslims,
especially the poor ones. And they
thought everything was fine, but then
they said it was them, it was they,
those Muslims who they grew up with, who
actually led ISIS to them and said, "Oh,
there are the Christians." So, that is
definitely a real thing that does happen
historically and in the present, which
is and there's doctrinal justification
for it. You know, taqiyya is one of the
main words, which basically means if
you're a Muslim and you're living under
infidel authority, deceit. Yeah, you
can, yeah. Basically, you can even
convert openly and become a Christian
and, you know, go have communion and get
baptized. You can actually, you can do
all that as long as in your heart you're
still a Muslim working for Islam. So,
that's the problem. How do you know if
this is really a moderate or if it's
someone who's doing that? And so, I
think the real problem is you have the
open radicals,
you have the moderates, the real
moderates, but then you have the gray
zone, which is a lot of these people who
appear moderate but could go they'll go
either way depending on who's stronger.
So, once Islam becomes strong, well,
okay, we'll go that way. But as long as
Islam looks weak, then we'll be like I
mean, they couldn't drink alcohol.
Also, before we continue, remember here
that, you know, the thing about trusting
your neighbor
we have another example, the genocide in
Rwanda, where the neighbors had the
machetes and they killed the other
neighbors that they had lived with all
their lives. So, it's not like it's it's
completely taken out like we have an
idea and it's never happened. It's
happened a lot. So, it's not it's not so
unusual that people had lived together
and then Yeah, just like that.
And then And it's really based on
circumstance, you know, as long as okay,
so let's say whatever creed I'm part of
that's not your part is weak. Okay,
well, of course I'm going to get along
with you. Once it gets strong and now I
don't have to get along with you, in
fact, I can subjugate you, then it
changes.
>> And that's what Danes understand because
we have a culture where we don't kill
the people that we have power over. No.
We don't really do that. I mean, it's
not like we're Danes, so everybody who's
not Danish must convert or be killed.
Right. That's our position, but that is
the Islamic position. And And that's so
outrageous that most Danes don't believe
it. I mean, I think it's it's it's if if
something is so outrageously against the
way you've been brought up and the the
world you've been told about, then it's
difficult to understand. I think this is
a problem. You asked me earlier, do the
politicians understand this in Denmark?
I think they don't because I mean, sure
there are those who are blindly
socialist and and moderate is
postmodernist They're They're not
interested in understanding anything
because they they believe that their
view of the ideal world is actually how
the world is. So, their idea of the
ideal world is everybody's nice to each
other. Ergo, the world must be like
that. It It's not, okay? Then there are
the the more right-wing people. I mean,
they the conservative the
We We could This sounds strange in in
American
parlor, but actually the liberals in
Denmark are on the right side. They're
not on the left side.
>> I might be wrong about that.
>> That's socialist. Um but the liberals
and the the free market capitalist
politicians and the conservatives are
all on on the right. I'm a libertarian,
so I'm even more on the right, but but
those people
they
are more open to the fact that the world
is not just how they want it to be, but
might be, you know, different. But that
that's a good position. Uh but but
still,
such a terrifying
concept or or or fact that a lot of
people like a million people in Denmark
eventually want to kill any citizen,
eventually under the right
circumstances.
That that's a problem because that that
all their belief that Denmark is
wonderful and we have few problems, that
would completely be crushed. Then then
Denmark is not wonderful and we have
huge problems. And that's not a nice
position to be in because then the next
question would be, well, why haven't you
done something to fix it? And
you know,
Yeah, it's much more it's comfortable
and easy to stick your head in the sand
and see there's no problem. Yeah, you
know, and and the only problem is your
free speech cuz it makes people angry.
Yeah, and and you know, so what they do
is they they they they say, well, that's
extremist and outrageous Rasmus that
you're saying that a lot of Muslims in
Denmark want to kill Danes eventually
and that's just you're so racist. I'm
saying, well,
Islam is not a race and Muslims are not
a race and you know, I actually I became
the the the chairman of Black Lives
Matter just to make a point, but the
point here is
they're using rhetoric to divert from
the real problem, of course. And the
real problem is that there are a lot of
people in Denmark from from the Muslim
world.
And that would be more or less all of
the people from the Muslim world in
Denmark who do not in their hearts agree
with the way we live.
And and and and you have to stop me from
saying something that's not true. And
and even more, most of them they just do
disagree. They they disagree, but most
of them are appalled. They think the the
way we live is very bad and and and
heathen and and um
you know, like animals. And how can you
have the position that people who have
that opinion of the other people in the
the
will will for all of their life live
heavily here. I mean, that's not going
to happen.
Well, I mean, as you just pointed out, I
think the first problem is they don't
have that. They don't want to
acknowledge that. The problem with a lot
of the
Western people, I think, is they just
project themselves. Like you said, you
know, they see, oh,
we're a happy, non-judgmental people. We
just want to get along. So, they project
that and assume, oh, of course, the
Muslims coming here feel the same way.
They just want to get along. They just
want to be happy. Okay. But, you know,
the Muslims who come from the Islamic
world bring a lot of baggage with them,
which is to say, they bring their own
culture, their own world view, their own
philosophy. And this goes back to really
the problem with multiculturalism. If
you really want to get to the heart of
it, okay, so the problem with Okay,
multiculturalism means what? All
cultures are equal and it's good to put
them all in a melting pot because it's
all great. Okay. The problem with that
is everyone thinks the word culture is
about dress and food, superficial
superficialities, okay? And
And so, what's wrong with that? That's
great. Multiculturalism means I can
have, you know, a falafel down the
street and gyros and I got Italian food
and Thai and Chinese and Indian food.
Oh, sounds great. Okay. That's the
superficial aspect of multiculturalism.
Now, what is really a culture? A culture
is actually a world view. It's a
philosophy. It's a theology. Most In
fact, if you really study it, cultures
are based on religion, ultimately, which
is why actually in the West, when you
know, because it doesn't have religion,
it's kind of losing its culture and it's
just becoming materialist. It has no
real vibrant culture. But anyway, so
that's the point. When you bring now a
Muslim who has his own culture, which is
to say, his own distinct world view,
which in many ways is antithetical to
Christian culture,
and you bring them here. Okay, yeah,
they they come here because they want to
enjoy the material goods. That makes
sense, the better life, as it were.
But then they, as you're pointing out,
they look at the lifestyle of, you know,
of Danes or Europeans in general and
they see them as complete heathens and
pagans and like you said animals. I mean
they do say that all the time. So So now
so that's the problem with
multiculturalism. You didn't bring one
group of people who dress in hijabs and
eat a certain food and mix them with
another group who dress and eat, you
know, European food. You brought a group
that hates and has nothing but contempt
for the way that group lives because
that's really what cultures are. And
that's why kind of multiculturalism
doesn't make sense. It's okay, I
believe. You can have a nation of
different races, but if they if they
share the same culture, which is not and
I don't mean just again by food. I mean
they have the same
worldview. They share they share the
same idea of right and wrong. Which is
also why it's interesting if you think
about it. This really underscores my
point. If you look at let's say
you know, if I told you okay, let's say
look at Denmark, right? Or let's say use
the United States cuz maybe that's a
better example. And let's say just look
at the white population which was the
majority historically.
>> Yeah, but let's say okay, let's say you
know, it was all still white, okay?
And so you would say they're the same
culture. Of course, I'd say no because
the extreme left-wing and the extreme
right-wing, they are so different that
they are culturally different.
Okay, so my point is you can be racially
homogeneous and actually be of different
cultures or you can be racially
heterogeneous, mixed up, but share the
same culture on a deeper level by which
I mean you share the same principles,
the same ethics, the same worldview and
you will get along. So my point is you
could actually theoretically have
different races living in one country,
but they share the same thing, they get
along. Or you could even just have one
race and they hate each other. Look at
the left and the right, they hate each
other. Okay, so that's I think one of
the big problems going back to what you
were saying about relativism with the
idea of multiculturalism.
Multiculturalism is you're forcing
contradictory worldviews and ethics and
you know, the way to do things, and
you're putting them together in this
case, Islam, which is okay with uh
tricking the infidel, lying, pretending
to go along with you, and then, you
know, once I'm in power, then I attack
you. And and Western Christian culture,
which is tolerant, open-minded, um you
know, giving, and uh you can see how
when you put those two together, one is
going to exploit the hell out of the
other.
I think uh this is obviously the truth,
but it's not something that many people
in Denmark would accept. Right, cuz it's
so terrifying. And and it's against what
they've been taught that people people
are like. And people are different. And
see, that's the thing. And that's just
the that you know, just to finish this
thought, the problem now in Western
culture is they've stripped it of its
Christian
mooring, and they think that So, today's
Dane, let's say, or the European, they
don't realize that their culture is
based on Christianity. They just think
that their culture is the final
refinement, and we've led the way, we've
dropped religion, and and all that, and
we are So, what they've really become
are materialists, because they have no
culture, and then they think everyone's
going to be like that.
Because but they don't realize that no,
they won't fit into this culture,
because this culture, like it or not, is
still based on Christianity.
>> And then this is
interesting, because Scandinavian
countries still to this day are in in in
incredibly Lutheran in the way they
behave, right? And most people don't
care. Exactly.
That's the thing about Western
civilization. You can be an atheist, but
you are kind of a Christian spite
knowing it.
>> Yeah, yeah. And then And then then then
the problem is you
What you're saying is actually kind of
an imperialist view they have, because
they have the audacity to believe that
our culture is so great that everybody
who comes here will immediately drive
them away.
It's bizarre. It's racist that you know,
oh, we're so superior, everybody will do
what we do now. And and you know, if we
go You're an American and I'm a Dane,
but we have kind of the same Christian
background in some ways. If we go to
Afghanistan and live there for two three
years, we're not going to say, "Oh, the
dancing boys excellent." You know?
That's not going to happen.
>> Yeah, exactly. But but I'm but the
Danes, the Swedes, and the Norwegians,
they think that if people come here and
I'm going to adopt or something, that's
just as alien to them.
>> It's just the opposite. It actually It
actually repulses them.
>> Yeah. And it may This is why it's
interesting. Who Who's the most radical?
It's usually the second, third
generation of Muslims. Yeah. It's not
the one who just came.
>> No. Which is amazing. You would think
the second, third generation would be
assimilated. Opposite. Opposite.
>> Because they they they they're born in
it, they see it, they hate it. It's so
repulsive to them naturally, and they
gravitate back to the
>> And that I must say I mean I know this,
of course, that when I walk around the
street and I see a Muslim, the the
chance of that person being repulsed by
the country that person is walking
around in is very, very high. I mean, I
wouldn't say 100%, but a very high
chance that that's the case. And and
they're not shouting that all the time
that we hate it, we're repulsed, you're
dirty. But if you pressure them a
little, then it comes out.
>> Right. And that's what happened when I
burned the Quran.
It's like, "We hate you." And then they
they threw rocks at 500 police officers,
you know? Yeah, it is.
It's finally the mask dropped.
>> Yeah, you know. You put enough pressure
to let them know that
>> This is what I actually feel about you
guys. So.
And and of course that that's goes That
was the terrifying part because And
that's that's what nobody said. I mean,
you I said, you know, this was bound to
happen. So, if you didn't understand
this, you were just stupid to live. But
but people didn't say, "This is He made
them actually show what they feel about
us." That's what they should have said.
All right, that's not what they said.
They said, "Oh, he was so He was so mean
to them." And I was like, "Well, most of
the places they rebelled, I wasn't even
there." So.
They attacked the police, and I wasn't
even there.
>> I know they're I'm sure the response is
hypocritical for the simple point that
if this if you or whoever did this with
a Bible and Christians responded in
violence, I guarantee you the
authorities would have swooped down on
them, made an example of them, there
would have been grandstanding about free
speech is our you know is is the highest
good, we have to preserve it, and we
don't we're not going to stand for you
for from this from Christians. But when
it's Muslims, you know, no, we don't do
that. It just goes to show you that free
speech is being weaponized, okay? And
free free speech against Christianity
exists and is promoted because
Christianity is under attack and that's
the way they want it. Islam, well, no,
that's that's a privileged religion.
I'm thinking another point that was also
I mean I'm talking now about this the
Easter riots that they're called. I call
them the Ramadan riots because Easter
and Ramadan was at the same time in 2022
in Sweden. That's something that didn't
happen in Denmark in 19, but it did
actually manifest itself very clearly in
in 2022 in Sweden, which was in my
opinion that
the Swedish police officers were
completely
unprepared for that amount of organized
violence. They had no
you know they they weren't prepared for
that because they had no training and
they had no mentality to to react to
that kind of organized
hateful violence because we when you
throw a rock at somebody repeatedly,
that's because you you really want to
hurt that person. And and and and you
know
they did they didn't understand I mean
they could understand to some point that
that the Muslims would hate me. Some of
the police officers probably hated me as
well. So because they saw me as the
reason for this.
>> Well, I'm not a troublemaker.
Troublemaker, you know, I'm I'm just
showing you what you're
reporting really, but
they they they couldn't understand
because it was so contrary to that
culture that you would actually en masse
take up stones and and rocks and throw
them at police officers to kill them.
And and you know, it's just like how
will you ever be able to protect your
citizenry if you don't understand that
you have to use
lethal force if necessary to protect
them. And and this is just like to to
illustrate the what you're talking about
that the the comprehension of how
different people can be in other parts
of the world is really lacking in in
Western Europe because they had to
understand Western Europe and not just
in Scandinavia but all Western Europe
that they are an extreme minority. Most
of the world is not like them. Sure, but
most of the world are not Muslim but
they're not like Western Europeans also.
The the the most of the world the
non-Western world would agree with what
Muslims when it comes to like you know
strict mores. Yeah. Absolutely. So the
the what do you call it the loose moral
values of Western Europe is the extreme
minority to most people in the world,
yeah? Not not just to Muslims, Yeah, but
to most people. And and
>> Which means the West is the aberration.
Yeah.
And and and you know and and then this
comes back to
um
uh what's the author who wrote the the
book about how the world would would
become after after the end of the Cold
War? What's his name? Um Samuel
Huntington? Yes. Or or the Fukuyama?
Hun- Huntington. Yeah, Huntington.
Huntington, he he basically said that
the the Western Europeans including you
know Australian Canada and America
they think that they have the power in
the world because everybody else agrees
that their culture is the better. But
that's not the reason at all. The reason
is they're better organized violence or
have been. Mhm. So what will happen when
they're no longer that? Which is where
we're at.
>> Yes. And this is so I mean Huntington
was pretty accurate in his prediction.
He also famously said you know the the
borders of Islam are bloody.
And it's innerds, too.
Yeah.
But um speaking of that uh here's
another observation and again it which
really underscores what you know either
the naivete or arrogance of Western
Western peoples, Europeans specifically
in this context, but
you know, the migration thing, right?
People feel compelled, yes, I have to be
I have to let, you know,
masses of people from black, brown,
yellow countries, whatever, come in,
okay? And I have to suppress my culture
and my heritage and humor them just like
in the case of the Quran burning, you
know, like we can't do that because we
have to appease them. Now, what's funny
is if you look at the globe and and and
imagine it even in colors, but let's
just give it numbers. Um whites are like
European whites are maybe like 5, 6% of
the entire world. And I find that
remarkable that the 5% is the one group
that feels it's it has to give up its
territory, its culture, suppress its
religion, and suppress its heritage to
appease the 95% of the world who wants
to come and take their land. And if you
look at the globe, I mean, Europe and
America and Australia, they look big,
okay, as far as But they don't have any
people. Exactly, that's what I'm saying.
If you if you could look at a a map, and
I have, of the world in in like, let's
say, dots represent races, okay? So, of
course, Africa and Asia are going to be
dark, but if you look at Europe and
America, they are, too. And and and
Australia. So, it's it's a 5, 6, 7%
depending on who you look at. And I just
find it amazing and suicidal that that's
the group that is being pressured the
most to do everything for the rest of
the world. And uh you know, that that's
what I'm trying to figure out that kind
of mentality and psychology.
Where does it come from?
And how is it nourished?
Unfortunately, I would be very rich if I
had the easy answer to that or if I
could fix everything. But but I mean,
certainly, we we've been around some of
the issues. I think we could just do a
quick follow-up on what happened with
the Quran ban in Denmark because after I
I burned a Quran in front of the embassy
of Turkey in in January '23, we had the
whole NATO gate where Erdogan was very
upset with me personally
for doing that. And then he he he said
Sweden cannot be a member because Rasmus
offended me in front of the embassy of
Turkey. He didn't say me, he said Islam,
but he meant me. But anyway,
uh him. He he he did that and we had the
whole and I was accused of of the
working for the Russians or what crazy
stuff. And then my What happened was I
went there on invitation because Erdogan
began meddling in the free speech of
Sweden which I opposed. Uh that he did.
So I went there for that reason, but you
know, people are crazy. Anyway,
eventually um Sweden and Finland joined
NATO, but in Denmark, some people I was
taken to a safe house by the security
police, so I couldn't be out in eight
months like it. You know, and and
threats from all over the world. They
had posters of me burning me and hitting
me with their sandals and all that. Oh,
yes, absolutely. Big protest. Uh
thousands of people, not just in Turkey,
but in all crazy I mean, Indonesia as
well. Um Well, it wouldn't be a good
idea for you to like go to Somalia or
Nigeria walking around with the open
Quran. To be fair, it wouldn't be good
for anybody. So I'm kidding.
But I'm not going to do that. Um but but
um the thing is
other people thought, "Hey, burning the
Quran seems fun. Let's do that in front
of the Muslim embassies in Copenhagen
800 times." And that's That was never my
point because yeah, I burned the Quran
once or twice for for MD. Otherwise, we
did it in areas where Muslims live.
That's completely disingenuous.
>> Right. So but that was the reasoning for
the Quran burning ban, not really what I
did, but what other people did. And then
of course, I was indicted and convicted
along with a friend because he held the
Quran and and we had a public debate at
a meeting. And he said, "What will
happen if I drop it in the pot of
water?" I said, "Bad idea, my friend.
Quran will get wet. Don't do it." He did
it. I was sentenced for for him to do
it. And uh the enticement apparently is
a don't do it, that's enticement in
Denmark apparently. But then um what
happened was we went to the appeals
court
and I said I'm a lawyer, so I said well
I'm the lawyer for my friend and myself.
And they said you can't do that. I said
I can do that. And then we appealed to a
special tribunal which is like very
rarely used in Denmark, like once a year
perhaps. But unfortunately for them it's
it's it's like a
a normal judge, an appeals judge, and a
highest supreme court judge and a lawyer
and a professor in in your student. So
they have five judges sitting there and
you had the right to be there in person.
And I if you demand it. And I said I
want to be there in person. And they're
like they never do this. So like us, you
know. And and so so far it's been like
four or five months so I haven't heard
anything and a position could be we have
elections now on Tuesday and is election
day.
Um unfortunately I'm not going to be
elected again, but but I'm I'm running
though. I'm on melt. But what will
happen is most people in the judiciary
probably hope that the new makeup of
parliament will repeal that law. Because
then their problem is done, you know,
their fix.
>> why they're waiting. That's why they're
waiting. So hopefully they will repeal
it and then we're done. Nobody wants to
deal with this anymore.
So that's just to update you if you're
interested in that what the things are
doing here in Denmark. It's not unusual
apparently for the courts to hope that
parliament will repeal the law so the
courts don't have to deal with it. I can
understand it because really who would
want to?
No. Yeah. So um and in America you don't
have the problem because you had a
pastor in Oh, I want to know about this.
You you had some people up in in um
what is that area north of Detroit?
Oh like a Muslim area? Oh yeah,
absolutely. Uh
um
Dearborn? Dearborn. Yeah. Somebody
burned the Quran there and it didn't go
very peacefully. Right. So is something
starting in America with people doing
that or is just a one-time thing? I
think it's more of a one-time thing. I
remember the first time I heard about
this in America was a long time ago with
some guy in Florida. Yeah. Older guy.
Reverend. Yeah. Yeah. But that didn't
get so much of attention. No.
>> Right. Right. But but the thing is now
we have video of stuff and the guy with
the with the commando uniform doing it
in Dearborn. That's like
And the thing the difference is when
I've done that in Denmark, there's
usually been some police. There is it
like Him and his guy.
Yeah.
I think as time goes by in general these
sorts of things these kind of just just
non-Muslims becoming more
confrontational against Muslims either
which way whether it's just by provoking
them or you know, up front. It's just
going to become more and more. You know,
it's
and so the clash kind of like what you
did bringing out the truth is going to
continue happening and it's going to
keep coming out more and more and you
know, the powers that be like you say
who don't want to deal with it want to
keep kicking the can down the road until
someone else's problem. Eventually it's
just going to become you know, too much.
Especially as the numbers keep growing.
The you know, the demographics as the
Muslims grow and not in the natives the
whites of wherever Europe start feeling
more and more pressure. You know, either
they're going to have to capitulate and
completely give up and be slaves or
they're going to have to do something
about it and it's just unfortunate that
they had to wait until it got so much
worse.
>> Yeah. That that's the problem.
>> That's why a country just real quick
like you know, Hungary and Poland these
countries they just problem right away.
Very simple. We said we don't want
Muslims and that's it. But now even if
you were to stop immigration, you still
have to deal with your native Muslim
population and their high birth rate
which is still going to be you know,
something. So, it's like you have to
live with it. Unless you can do
remigration. Yeah. And and you know,
remigration is the only solution and and
that can't be a voluntary remigration
because okay, sure if you take away the
benefits some will leave. That's true.
But otherwise, they're just in a cold
donation for nothing.
Yeah, exactly. So so but it won't be all
because some of them are have money, you
know. So
and they will you know have to live by
the sword really. And and you know, this
is something that Oh, we're so peaceful.
Well, you know, peaceful.
If if you're only peaceful if somebody's
at war with you, then you get killed.
That's basically in I don't understand
this, okay? Because I was I was
ostracized when I said in this famous
speech in 2016 that our
our streets and and and and and and
streets will be rivers of blood. And I
thought, how can you say that? I
thought, well, what I said was if we're
attacked in a war and they're coming for
us, then we kill them and then their
blood will will, you know, run in the
streets. That's what war is. And and for
people who haven't really experienced
that, it's just like even talking about
it is like, well, that's what you want.
No, that's not what I want, but sure, if
somebody attacks us and wants to kill
us, I want us to kill them first. And I
was like,
It's very basic. But you know, I just
yelled that loud in 2016 because I
figured, might as well tell you now that
this is what the the future is for you.
So, you know, wake up, people. And and
and this was 2016. Now, that's 10 years
ago. I can't really say it was proven
wrong in any way in any measurement
because things have just become a lot
worse. And and that's what Danish people
some of them are kind of finding out.
They just don't still understand what
what's necessary to deal with the
situation because, you know,
uh as I Huntington said, we should
That's not what he said, but he said,
Western Europe very good at organized
violence. Well, maybe we should use
that, you know, um
great quality apparently because
otherwise, you know, we we can't we
can't um
Is Islam integrating into something
else? Has that ever happened? No. No.
Not sincerely. No, not sincerely. I
mean, yeah, pretend. Well, that has
happened, but sincerely integrating
hasn't happened because it's impossible
and and and no Muslim wants it. Exactly.
There's examples throughout history
where, you know, the like I said, when
Muslims are weak and they're under
infidel authority, they pretended they
pretended to convert to Christianity and
there so they went generations. So,
let's say one Muslim converted, his son
became a Christian and their grandson.
And then the Spaniards finally found out
like five generations later, that guy
who seemed the model Christian was still
at home a Muslim preaching hate for
infidels, reading the Quran and spitting
on the cross and things like that. Um
so, that's the problem. It's very And
again, I'm to be realistic, I'm not
saying every single Muslim. The problem
is Here's a problem, okay? There is a
moderate radical dichotomy, but the
words do us no service, okay? The
There are two groups and one is
obviously not as problematic, but it's
not that he's moderate and the other guy
is a radical. The bad guy is the true
Muslim. Yes, that's it. He ISIS with the
true Bible. Yes. He's They are
practicing true normative historical
doctoral Islam. The other guy is not
moderate, he's just not a Muslim. He's
culturally Muslim. He's He calls himself
he prays Muhammad. Tho- Those are the
old Byzantines. Yeah, I think. You know,
They they they That's they've been
they've been in a in a in a secular
society under the Cold War for so long
that yeah, they call themselves Muslim,
but if somebody burns the Quran, it's
like, yeah, you know, that that that So,
that's what we mean by a moderate, but
but the words themselves are really
tricky because what is a moderate Muslim
mean? What he's moderating the truth?
And he's saying, "Oh, this part of the
Quran I'm not accepting, but I'll accept
I mean, this is sort of a
Sharia is part of Islam and Hadith is
part of Islam and particularly the Quran
is part of Islam. So, so if you're
moderate, you discard half of the Quran?
>> Exactly.
>> That's absurd. That's like saying,
"Well, I'm a Christian and I believe
that Jesus died on the cross but not
that he was ascended to heaven."
>> Right. That's like, "Okay, well, then
you're not a Christian."
>> Exactly. That's the point. That's the
point. So, the moderate Muslims, I'm not
arguing that they are, they do exist,
but it's not because they're moderate.
It's just they're not really Muslims.
>> Exactly.
>> That's it. And the ones who are a
headache, they're the real Muslims. So,
yes, there is a division, but it's not
what people want them They want to act
like the bad guys are these weird
radical aberrations that No, no, that's
that's Islam. Always been Islam.
I I
When Muslims say to me like, "No, no,
no, ISIS were very bad." I said, "Well,
that's true. They killed a lot of
Muslims, but but they were the true
Muslims."
Well, the the Muslims that they killed
would be seen as heretics and not real
Muslims.
>> That's why they were killed. Exactly.
So
So, so you may think you're Muslim, but
if you study your religion a bit more,
then you will find out are you actually
a Muslim or are you not? And that's
that's what I tried to say in more
subtle way to the Turk yesterday, you
know.
Are you a Muslim or are you not? Because
apparently in the 5 minutes we spoken, I
told you more about your religion than
you knew about your religion. And and I
know There's a lot of that, too. I see
that a lot in America where, you know,
Muslims who There's There's Muslims who
don't know the first thing about their
religion.
>> know the five pillars. I mean, they know
nothing.
>> Okay, so how are you a Muslim at this
point?
So, that's what I mean. They're just
cultural Muslims, you know, they they
hang out with their friends and maybe
they go to mosque once every month or
two or do they do the kind of Ramadan
they feast at night with their buddies?
Okay, so it's not necessarily that
they're at heart true Muslims.
>> No, no. And and and and and this is a
problem because, you know, the the
people who are actually going to destroy
our societies, those are the true
Muslims.
And the others, well, they would
probably follow my otherwise they'll be
killed as well. Exactly. Yep. Or Or like
we said, when when Islam gets stronger
then they shift Yeah.
>> They'll let that They'll be then they'll
become more like
>> and then to be fair, you know, um this
remind me of of my interview with Brad
Johnson that I I said to him that in in
Denmark, young Muslim males, they're
they're more, you know,
Eager to attack a Danish guy when
they're fighting against one. And then
he said, well, yes, but that's not
necessary because they're Muslims, it's
also, you know, strategically wise. And
this is the same thing, you know, if
you're really not a Muslim but
culturally Muslim and all of the sudden
Muslims rule, then would it be more
adapt I mean would it be more wise to
say, oh no, I'm not really a Muslim or
to say, yeah, I can kill my neighbor
then I'm not killed. They're just
flexible. They if if the Danes are
strong, then oh, I'm I'm on your side.
If the Muslims become strong, then yeah.
Yeah, and that's the difference because
that's not the way Danes are. Danes are
not flexible. They are like, well, we're
always Danes. And then he well, and
that's the difference.
It's just amazing all these countries
and the way they're just they all, you
know, giving their nations away like
that. It's just a
It's it's really
>> more and more contempt. That's the
thing. A lot of the, you know, your
Western Europeans, they think the more I
give, this appeases the Muslims.
>> That's the opposite. It breeds contempt.
The the the the Muslims in Denmark, many
of them hate me. But But they probably
kind of respect you in a way. Yeah,
because they see I'm strong, you know,
and I don't take Yeah. So, they're
like, okay, well, he's fat but at least
he's strong.
>> Yeah. He at least he stands every
you know, 10 years he said our prophet
Sucks. So, at least he's consistent.
And and and you know, um and and
actually um when you say something to
him and you're threatening, he's just
like, well, screw you and you shouldn't
speak like that. And and that's the
>> That reminds me of the Muslim
perspective towards the Crusaders and
especially the military orders. So, you
know, if you as I have done in in one of
my recent book, if you really look at
how they talked about them. On the one
hand, they they hated them and they
really feared them but you they
respected them.
>> Yeah. Cuz these were Christians who were
dying for their faith, who took no crap
from Islam, you know, so they they
earned their respect.
>> Yeah. And and that's, you know, if
you're if you if you don't show fear and
you're controlling and and you they
sense that you're willing to use
violence if necessary, that It means
you're like them. Yes. And they they
they can respect that. You're like me.
Conscious level, you don't know you
know. And then physically they think of
it We know this, the young men are more
aggressive than older men. We know this.
And I'm a little older than the young
men, so I'm also like the rais. Yeah.
The the leader.
They they It's not not on a conscious
level, but on unconscious level
there is something there. Respect for
the elder. Yeah, respect for the elder
cuz they as long as I maintain that, you
know, I'm not I'm not phased by their
aggression.
>> Right, right. You know, I mentioned
earlier, you know, so those those things
are something that the Europeans should
learn from, but of course they don't. I
wrote an article maybe 20 years ago, I
called it Islam, the schoolyard bully.
And I basically described, you know, the
schoolyard bully, which is basically,
you know, he starts testing you out and
pushing you. And the more you give in,
the more he aggressive he is and he
pushes you and he treats you like a
slave. But the moment you give him a
strong punch in the nose and the more
you take a stand, then he becomes your
best best friend. And in many ways, that
really
typifies Islam on the global scene.
That's kind of the behavior that I've
seen. So, that's why I'm actually trying
to teach younger people in Denmark now
that, you know, you need to know your
enemy a little bit and and sometimes you
don't even need to use your muscles, you
can use your psychology. Yeah. And you
know what? Exactly. You know this. But
the appeasement thing, which they're so
dedicated to, the more we're going to
appease them, we're they're going to
like us, it does the exact opposite. It
breeds contempt.
>> is even the security police in Denmark
don't know this because they they told
me like, "Try to be conflict escalating
de-escalating." And that doesn't work.
That's the opposite they need. You tell
"You need to stand back, otherwise we'll
have trouble, you know." That's what
they need. They don't need "Oh, I'm
sorry that I offended you." Like if the
So, this is a problem.
>> That's what they would respect, the
former. Yeah, yeah, the former.
Absolutely. And you know, and they've
seen the videos where I'm like they've
never they've never seen any dangerous
person act like this, you know? Somebody
came up, this is many years ago, this is
in 2018, and and I was I called them the
Sharia police because they were at the
protest and they were like elder
Muslim males trying to to de- de- de-
aggressive their their younger because
the young people were very aggressive so
they tried to calm them. And and that's
this kind of
ruined my optics. So, I I thought I
could do something about this. So, I
said, "Oh, we have a grandfather here
and he's he's tried to do something."
And then a young guy came up and said,
"Muslim,
he's a respected man. You shouldn't
disrespect him." And I kind of like did
the "No, he's not. He's garbage." And
then of course everybody thought he was
fallen. So, you know, you have to know
the culture in order to interact in a
good way. Raymond, it was a real
pleasure and seemed like more of a
conversation than an interview, but I
hope um
your viewers and my viewers will enjoy
this. I I had a blast.
>> Me, too. Good. It was good of good doing
it. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back
and the righteous